[Musica]
nei giorni scorsi stavo sfogliando il
financial times quando mi sono imbattuto
in questo annuncio
siate preparati dice il financial times
perché il new normal sta arrivando e
sarà un new normal molto digitale sempre
più digitale ei dubbi sembrano essere
pochi perché in questo new normal avremo
tanto smart working avremo il
distanziamento sociale per la nostra
quotidianità avremo modo di apprendere
ed imparare fatto di strumenti di
piattaforme come webex come zoom e tutte
le altre cose che abbiamo conosciuto in
queste settimane di lockdown prima e poi
di riapertura dopo nessun dubbio
ecco fatemelo dire direttamente non sono
d'accordo
non credo che sarà così semplice e non
credo che questo mio norman sarà così
tanto digitale sono un po condizionato
in questo da quello che ha scritto una
finta leda l'autore de il cigno nero il
quale diceva attenzione perché l'uomo è
troppo sicuro di sé quando immagina e
disegna il futuro siamo 22 volte troppo
sicuri rispetto a quello che dovremmo
essere dice taleb e citando alcuni studi
scientifici
io sono d'accordo anche perché spesso
noi formuliamo delle ipotesi partendo da
prove deboli e poi queste idee che
formuliamo sono i davis cose che restano
molto attaccate e di cui noi facciamo
una gran fatica per cercare di liberarci
e allora vorrei in questa conversazione
provare a immaginare insieme a voi come
sarà questo new normal non ho molte
certezze come avrete intuito ma ho
qualche punto di partenza che vorrei
condividere con voi
innanzitutto ogni crisi lascia sul
terreno cambi che sono temporanei e
cambi che sono permanenti temporanei
significa che molte cose che abbiamo
visto in queste settimane l'uso della
mascherina questo ricorso così massiccio
lo smart working probabilmente non
faranno parte del futuro rada nel quale
opereremo cambi invece permanenti sono
cose che quando la polvere si sara
posata presteranno e cambieranno in modo
stabile no come fosse uno scalino il
nostro modo di vivere il nostro modo di
lavorare ogni ogni crisi ha lasciato
dietro di sé dei cambi permanenti la
seconda guerra mondiale ad esempio
consegnò la storia
la società una donna più protagonista e
ruolo delle donne cambiò sul
palcoscenico sociale globale la crisi
dell'undici settembre per esempio ha
determinato una profonda riscrittura
delle regole di sicurezza sugli aerei
nei cieli e questa cosa è rimasta
diciamo fin se ormai oggi abbiamo una
sensibilità molto molto forte questo
nuovo scenario ma anche la sars nel 2002
l'altra epidemia ha cambiato ha cambiato
molto intanto l'idea che ci potesse
essere ed esistere un commercio diverso
rispetto al commercio fisico l'e
commerce per molti la comparsa dei
grandi colossi come alì babà origine
proprio da quella crisi da un modo nuovo
di vedere il commercio è anche la crisi
del 2007 quella dei sub prime americani
che ha come dire azzoppato i mercati
finanziari di tutto il mondo ha lasciato
comunque una eredità positiva ed è stata
una maggiore sensibilità nei confronti
della cosiddetta si è sala corporate
social responsability la domanda dunque
è ma quando veramente tutto si sarà
placato e torneremo alla nostra
regolarità quale sarà questo il new
normal sarà quello che dice le fan ange
al times cioè digital parzialmente sì ma
ci saranno anche delle altre cose
intanto io credo che il digitale sia un
po come il colore per la televisione
colore che arrivò negli stati uniti a
metà degli anni cinquanta in italia un
po dopo nel 76
e così come il colore non cambiò la
qualità della televisione la percezione
sì ma non determinò una tv migliore
rispetto a prima così io credo che il
digitale non sia quella formula magica
che rende le nostre aziende più longeve
più sensibili più forti più innovative
più competitive anche magari più più
accoglienti è un diciamo un mezzo non è
un fine
da allora che cosa realmente cambierà
allora io credo che saranno quattro gli
ambiti in cui ci troveremo a combattere
ea ridefinire le regole
intanto il ruolo dei governi dei governi
sarà diverso rispetto a quello che
attualmente lo abbiamo visto e io
immagino che su questo molte cose
verranno dette molte cose verranno
scritte e decise la logistica e un'altra
idea di sostenibilità saranno un altro
elemento su cui tutti quanti noi saremo
chiamati
a confrontarci il comportamento dei
consumatori sarà il terzo aspetto che
inevitabilmente cambierà sta già
cambiando in queste settimane in questi
giorni noi lo stiamo vedendo e lo
vedremo sempre più ed infine e su questo
tornerò fra poco cambierà il senso che
noi diamo al nostro lavoro e alla nostra
presenza nella società e soprattutto a
livello di economia e di mercati provo a
fare un passo più avanti e dirvi due
cose che mi hanno molto colpito e che
secondo me faranno parte dell'album di
famiglia della new normality negli
ultimi sei mesi ho letto almeno cinque
ricerche in modo chiaro e forte hanno
sottolineato questo aspetto le persone
il mercato gli studenti
diciamo molte audience stanno chiedendo
alle grandi aziende alle medie aziende
ai brand di avere più coraggio di dire
le cose con più determinazione con più
forza non è soltanto un'impressione sono
anche serve sono anche dati e ricerche
che dicono queste e questo fenomeno lo
stiamo già vedendo questa brand
revolution nel senso che i brand e le
aziende iniziano a intervenire su
questioni anche spinose anche divisive
sta un po osservandosi negli stati uniti
in particolare ma anche in europa e
anche il nostro paese in italia e che
cosa dicono i consumatori quando
rispondono a delle serve su questo per
esempio hanno risposto ad una ricerca di
edelman nelle ultime settimane è stata
presentata secondo cui il 74 per cento
delle persone chiedono ai brand di avere
più coraggio più coraggio nel parlare di
cambiamento climatico nel parlare di
diseguaglianza di immigrazione di
disabilità cioè di avere quel coraggio
che molti oggi credono che governi e
istituzioni abbiano un po perso per la
strada state attenti perché questo
elemento sarà un elemento portante è
fondamentale della new normality ci sono
tutti esempi che mi hanno colpito le
nike se andate a vedere i loro spot
anche procter gamble sono estremamente
assertive queste aziende nel dire delle
cose questo non determina soltanto
aspetti positivi anzi forse sono più gli
aspetti negativi e i contraccolpi a
livello di reputazione almeno nella fase
iniziale rispetto ai benefici e
sicuramente e questa è una cosa su cui
conviene essere chiari subito questa
posizione diversa delle aziende e delle
società non è legata ad un tema di
business development si direbbe cioè di
commercializzazione di volontà di
vendere più prodotti e più servizi
c'è un secondo aspetto che mi ha molto
colpito in questi mesi
io credo che nella new normale che
nessuno di noi vorrà comprare prodotti
servizi lavorare avere familiari
coinvolti all'interno di aziende che non
abbiano chiare il senso e il loro scopo
più profondo e quello che noi abbiamo
chiamato polpo che cos'è questo porto se
poi cos'è che cosa c'è in fondo al dna
di un'azienda quale fu il motivo per cui
un'azienda nacque magari cento anni fa
magari sei mesi fa perché anche le start
up anno hanno i loro porti ma questo
corpo si proietta su tutto quello che
l'azienda e su tutto quello che
l'azienda dice su tutto quello che
l'azienda fa e produce e porcos
sostanzialmente è il motivo per il quale
un'azienda ma anche noi stessi esistiamo
ed avremo un ruolo nella società ed è
molto semplice capire se questo portò
esiste o non esiste basta rispondere ad
una domanda che ma se domani la mia
organizzazione la mia azienda
scomparisse che cosa avrebbe perso il
mondo rispondere a questa domanda da già
una buona approssimazione rispetto al
significato profondo che un'azienda vive
e che trasmette alle sue persone che
trasmette al mercato trasmette ai
dipendenti e trasmette a quelli che si
chiamano generalmente gli stakeholder ma
non li possiamo chiamare tutti coloro
che sono impattati dall'attività di
un'azienda
vorrei lasciarvi con due esempio con due
storie che mi hanno particolarmente
colpito di due aziende che al loro
interno hanno molto di digitale ma che
si sono ritrovati dopo essersi smarrite
un grazie al digitale o non soltanto
grazie a trasformazioni digitali ma
perché hanno riallacciato come dire i
fili del presente alla loro cultura alla
loro storia a quel 7 di valori che avete
capito costituiscono tutti insieme
quello che abbiamo definito in modo
abbastanza ampio porthos la prima
azienda un'azienda antica in azienda che
che ha quasi 110 anni un'azienda che ha
innovato molto anche socialmente
soprattutto quando è nata a inizio
novecento negli stati uniti questa
azienda negli anni 80 ha rischiato di
perdersi di smarrirsi è stata veramente
vicina al fallimento questa azienda si
chiama ibm è un'azienda che esiste e che
noi conosciamo molto bene con cui
abbiamo ovviamente un rapporto a livello
di brand e in un bellissimo libro dal
titolo chi lo ha detto che gli elefanti
non sanno danzare lewis kershner che fu
colui che traghettò ibm dal momento più
buio a momenti più felici racconta come
quell operazione di salvataggio o
quantomeno di turn around fu compiuta
all'inizio degli anni 90 e fu compiuta
proprio perché racconta ghersi nel in
questo libro la cultura tornò ad essere
non un elemento del gioco ma il gioco
stesso
il gioco stesso e la sopravvivenza per
ibm non era tanto nel prodotto non era
tanto nella trasformazione digitale nei
processi tutti elementi importanti ma
era nel far rivivere quella scintilla
iniziale che 110 anni prima i fondatori
avevano lanciato e che poi si era un po
perduta e la cui proiezione non si
percepiva e non si vedeva più oggi sul
mercato
l'altro esempio è un altro brand si
direbbe iconico che fa parte del nostro
vissuto sicuramente del mio
sicuramente mi permetto di dire del
vostro sicuramente dei miei figli ed è
un'azienda che ha perso il proprio tocco
magico verrebbe da dire
nel corso degli anni anche questa è una
storia pazzesca che può bikers l'attuale
amministratore delegato oggi oggi
presidente racconta in un libro
recentemente pubblicato questa azienda e
disney e ad un certo punto disney si
rende conto
non essere più quella azienda che ogni
cosa che toccava trasformava in qualche
cosa di fenomenale i personaggi sono
importanti ma restano quelli del
novecento
i nuovi personaggi non sfondano non si
vendono le loro magliette non vengono
celebrati nelle feste nelle teste dei
bambini questi personaggi non fanno
parte come tanti altri di disney e anche
in questo caso quello che avviene è un
lavoro prima ancora che sul digitale che
per disney oggi è tremendamente
importante sui valori sulla cultura e
anche in questo caso è anche in questo
caso sul palco se puoi sognare puoi
farlo diceva il polpo di disney ma di
fatto non esisteva più o quantomeno non
è più vissuto e messo in pratica ogni
giorno per cui la domanda che il bayern
l'amministratore delegato un giorno si
pose è ma se oggi rivivesse la
principessa disney che tipo di cose
dovremmo fare per trasmettere quel senso
di meraviglia alle persone che comprano
quegli oggetti che vedono i nostri film
che vanno nei nostri parchi e così via
quindi rispondere a questa domanda
perché disney nacque e quelle sensazioni
oggi come le trasmettiamo questa magia
si era persa e un profondo ripensamento
e una ri partenza da quelle cose ha
consentito di fare delle cose
formidabili acquisizioni marvel pixar
lucas film e tante altre acquisizioni
che ha fatto disney negli anni ma
soprattutto di svoltare e di avere un
altro passo eco per concludere io penso
che in quel new normal che citavamo
all'inizio della nostra conversazione
anche il polpo è l'idea chiara dei
motivi per cui un'azienda esiste e di
ciò che trasmette quotidianamente alle
proprie audience farà sicuramente parte
da adesso in poi grazie
[Musica]